war 100.000 corona tote in deutschland
ja das robert koch institut meldet heute
morgen dass die zahl der menschen die an
oder unter beteiligung einer
nachgewiesenen infektion mit 19
gestorben sind auf 100.000 119 ist sie
gestiegen ja das ist also eine schwelle
die deutschland damit erreicht hat diese
zahl von
100.000 corona toten sozusagen ist ein
meilenstein in dieser corona krise und
wir wollen natürlich darüber sprechen
was machen wir mit dieser zahl jetzt was
bedeutet diese gigantische zahl ist das
viel einmal ganz provokant gefragt das
wollen wir wissen von unserem bild
meinung chef philippe piatti also
hunderttausend das löst natürlich in uns
allen erstmal schrecken aus angst aus
und auch sorge vor dem was da noch kommt
in den nächsten wochen in den nächsten
monaten wir wollen rational einmal ein
einordnen 100.000 corona tote was
bedeutet diese zahl
100.000 krone tote ist natürlich viel
alles andere zu behaupten wäre einfach
zynisches gt 100.000 menschen die mit
oder ancona gestorben sind es ist ja
nicht immer ganz klar viele menschen
hatten vorerkrankungen ist das viel im
internationalen vergleich müsste man
sagen nein das ist nicht so viel wenn
wir uns beispielsweise frankreich
österreich großbritannien die usa
italien anschauen riester zahl da da
sind
pro einwohner sind dort deutlich mehr
menschen gestorben also selbst in
schweden beispielsweise auch da sind
bislang deutlich mehr menschen gestorben
20 bis 30 prozent mehr pro einwohner
gerechnet deswegen diese zahl
hunderttausend das ist für deutschland
eine sehr große zahl für die usa ist das
zum beispiel eine relativ kleine zahl
weil das land einfach viel größer ist
die frage ist aber glaube ich nicht nur
dass viele im internationalen vergleich
sondern wir sind eigentlich die menschen
die gestorben sind woher woher kommen
die und da ist die bittere antwort das
sind zu einem sehr großen teil bewohner
von alten- und pflegeheim die im winter
2020 gestorben sind weil sie nicht
geschützt wurden weil eigentlich gewarnt
wurde dass man diese menschen schützen
muss dass es eine testpflicht braucht
für das alte dass die menschen schnell
geimpft werden müssen all das ist nicht
passiert
die bundesregierung hat das thema leider
nicht ernst genug genommen hat lieber
auf allgemeine lockt dann maßnahmen
gesetzt und erst viel zu spät gemerkt
dass diese menschen jetzt besonderes
geschützt werden soll jetzt also dieser
werde jetzt geknackt wurde sage ich mal
ganz salopp gesagt hat dass irgendwelche
konsequenzen wird es jetzt doch den
locker und für alle geben weil diese
zahl jetzt da ist nein ich glaube diese
zahl hat keine politische bedeutung was
nicht heißt dass wir ihn kein locker und
erleben werden ich glaube da deutschland
steuert gerade auf irgendeine art von
lockdown zu weil die zahlen steigen vor
allem weil die intensivstationen voller
werden aber das ist erst mal eine zahl
die uns einfach anregen sollte nochmal
an krone über kroner nachzudenken auch
natürlich an den menschen zu der
menschen zu gedenken die gestorben sind
dann kein bild meinung chefin pia topf
zu der zahl 100.000 corona tote die
heute deutschland bewegt und seine
meinung zu dieser zahl von philippe
piatti vielen dank